[Musique]
une devise pour devenir un consommateur
responsable
voilà le message passé dans ce village
zéro déchet chaque année près de 800
millions de tonnes de déchets sont
produits en france
un constat inquiétant mais avec des
gestes simples chacun peut limiter sa
production qu'il ne fallait pas
gaspiller qu'il vous fallait trouver des
moyens pour recycler le compost qu'il
fallait recycler les choses de bien
faire le tri pour pas polluer de pas
jeter les choses dehors
l'un partout une soixantaine d'élèves du
chesnay et de rocquencourt ont écouté
les conseils toute la matinée découverte
des achats en vrac pour éviter le sur
emballage de l'éco conception ou de la
lutte contre le gaspillage alimentaire
plusieurs thématiques abordées avec les
membres de l'association y ça devient
concret il se projette eux dans leur
quotidien avec ses petites façon de
faire c'est qu'ils prennent les bonnes
habitudes les bons réflexes
les bonnes façons d'aborder la
consommation de bien réfléchir avant
d'acheter une première pour versailles
grand parc
la communauté d'agglomération organise
ce village en partenariat avec
l'association et le sictom ca le
syndicat en fait par lequel sont traités
les ordures ménagères notamment des
villas du chéné vélizy et versailles on
sent vraiment touchée par cet art ce
sujet par cette thématique et du coup ça
va rafraîchir et ils sont unis véhicule
hier le message auprès des parents aussi
sensibiliser aussi le grand public qui
pourra venir visiter le village jusqu'au
26 novembre à l'hôtel de ville